Japan is preparing to host its Western
allies the country the only Asian member
of the G7 will preside over a summit
meeting which once again is likely to be
dominated by the war in Ukraine
15 months on after the Russian invasion
the G7 will decide how to further
support the Ukrainian government
militarily and financially Ukraine's
made some recent gains around the town
of bakmut and there's much speculation
about a possible counter-offensive using
new weapons supplied by NATO allies it's
a Time analysts say which could be key
to the Future direction of the conflict
the stakes for Ukraine are incredibly
high and there is concern that unless
Ukraine is successful this year with the
significant support it has had it could
be significantly harder to Rally as much
support in the future China has sent a
peace Envoy Lee Hue to Ukraine here
meeting with foreign minister dimitro
kaleba the G7 must decide how to react
to the Chinese peace initiative but
privately many of its members are
skeptical given China's continuing
strong diplomatic alliance with Moscow
President Biden boarding Air Force one
has said he's still hoping to meet with
China's president XI adding the words
whether it's soon or not for the next
few days the U.S leader will be
concentrating on the G7 while his
advisors keep him in touch with ongoing
political discussions with Republicans
at home to stop the U.S defaulting on
its debt the venue of this year's G7 is
highly symbolic the place where the
first nuclear bomb was dropped in 1945
anti-nuclear campaigners are hoping it
will concentrate the minds of seven of
the most important people on Earth James
Bay's Al Jazeera Hiroshima